a
OFFICE IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ;
COLOR IN STATE LEGISLATURES, IN
LOCAL CITY COUNCILS, AND ALSO A;
a
THE FEDERAL LEVEL BECAUSE WHEN ;
COLOR IN THESE STATE HOUSES,
THEY MAKE NEW POLICIES FOR ;
a
.
THEY CHANGE SOCIETY.
>> THAT IS PHILANTHROPIST
MELINDA FRENCH GATES.
SHE'S OF COURSE A COFOUNDER OF ;
a
THE BILL AND MELINDA GATES
FOUNDATION.
THAT FOUNDATION HAS GIVEN AWAY ;
a
MORE THAN $70 BILLION IN GRANTS;
AND GIRLS, SHE IS NOW FOCUSED ON
GETTING MORE WOMEN ELECTED TO
FRENCH GATES EXPLAINS WHY IN A
RECENT OP-ED, QUOTE, ONLY ONE I;
a
THREE STATE LEGISLATURES IN THE;
U.S. IS A WOMAN, AND AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IT'S CLOSER TO ONE
IN FOUR
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT WOMEN
GOVERN DIFFERENTLY, WORKING MORE
COLLABORATIVELY ACROSS PARTY ;
a
LINES AND INTRODUCING
LEGISLATION ON ISSUES THAT HAVE;
a
HIS TO
TORICALLY GONE.
I SPOKE WITH HER ABOUT THOSE ;
a
EFFORTS, ALSO HER CONCERNS WITH;
AI AND LIFE AFTER HER VERY ;
a
>> SO YOU START THIS OP-ED IN ;
TIME WRITING IN 1976 ANNABELLE
CLEMENTE BRIAN RAN ON THE SLOGAN
A WOMAN'S PLACE IS IN THE HOUSE;
a
AND THE SENATE TOO.
WHY IS SO MUCH OF YOUR EFFORT ;
a
MORE WOMEN ELECTED?
>> WELL, BECAUSE I BELIEVE WOME;
a
SHOULD HAVE THEIR FULL POWER AN;
AND IN 2019 I MADE A BILLION
DOLLARS COMMITMENT TO ENSURE
THAT REALLY STARTS TO HAPPEN
MORE, WITH MORE MOMENTUM, AND
I'M JUST SEEING THAT WE AREN'T
THERE YET.
DOWN, TOO OFTEN WE HAVE ;
a
DECISIONS BEING MADE FOR WOMEN,;
NOT BY WOMEN, AND AS SHE SAID ;
a
AND ALSO AS RUTH BADER GINSBURG
SAID, I BELIEVE WOMEN SHOULD BE;
a
BEING MADE, AND THAT'S JUST -- ;
WE'RE JUST NOT THERE YET AS A
COUNTRY.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT YOUR
EFFORT IS YOU'RE REALLY KEENLY
FOCUSED ON STATE LEGISLATURES, ;
a
?
>> WELL, I'M FOCUSED ON MAKING ;
a
SURE THAT WOMEN HAVE THEIR
RIGHTFUL PLACE AT ALL LEVELS OF;
a
GOVERNING, BUT STATE LEGISLATOR;
THERE ARE 7,000 SEATS AT THE ;
a
LEGISLATIVE LEVEL AT STATES.;
THEY CONTROL $2 TRILLION IN ;
a
RESOURCES, AND THEY MAKE REALLY;
IMPORTANT POLICIES AND LAWS THA;
a
AFFECT EVERYONE IN THEIR STATE.;
SO REALLY FOCUSING THERE WHERE ;
a
FOR THOSE WOMEN WHO DO WANT TO ;
CONGRESS IT'S A GREAT TRAINING
GROUND.
>> DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS YO;
a
?
.
WE NEED OUR GOVERNMENT TO ;
a
REPRESENT ALL OF US, AND WE HAV;
DEPENDING ON WHAT STATE YOU'RE ;
a
IN, DEPENDING ON YOUR POLITICAL
LEANINGS.
SO ABSOLUTELY, BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
>> FORMER REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY WAS ;
a
QUITE BLUNT SPEAKING IN NEW YOR;
THIS WEEK, HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID;
a
>> WHAT WE'VE DONE IN OUR
POLITICS IS CREATE A SITUATION ;
a
WHERE WE'RE ELECTING IDIOTS.;
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND SO I DON'T LOOK AT IT ;
a
THROUGH THE LENS OF LIKE, YOU
KNOW, IS THIS WHAT I SHOULD DO ;
a
OR WHAT I SHOULDN'T DO.
I LOOK AT IT THROUGH THE LENS O;
a
AND I THINK ELECTING SERIOUS ;
.
>> I'M WONDERING IF YOU AGREE,
IF YOU THINK THAT ELECTING MORE
WOMEN HELPS SOLVE THAT PROBLEM?;
a
THAT EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY'S;
R
a
A MALE.
WE HAVE TO REALIZE WE JUST
AREN'T THERE YET.
ONE THIS THREE STATE LEGISLATORS
ARE WOMEN.
ONE IN FOUR ARE WOMEN IN ;
a
.
HOW CAN WE HAVE 16 MILLION BLAC;
a
WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY BUT ZERO
BLACK SENATORS?
SO WE KNOW THAT POINT OF VIEW ;
a
ISN'T BEING REPRESENTED, AND WE
NEED TO DO MORE TO MAKE SURE ;
a
PUBLISHED REALLY AT THE ONE-YEAR
MARK OF ROE VERSUS WADE BEING
OVERTURNED.
WAS THAT A COINCIDENCE?
>> NOT AT ALL A COINCIDENCE.
I MEAN TO HAVE A LAW ON THE
BOOKS FOR ALMOST 50 YEARS AROUND
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND
THEN HAVE IT ROLLED BACK, AND
WHEN YOU REALLY GO AND TALK TO ;
a
AND DO THE RESEARCH ABOUT WHAT
DO AMERICANS BELIEVE, THEY
BELIEVE THAT LAW SHOULD BE IN ;
a
PLACE.
SO TO ME IT WAS A DECISION,
AGAIN, WHERE A DECISION MADE FO;
a
WOMEN, NOT BY WOMEN.
WE SHOULD NEVER ROLL BACK A LAW;
a
LIKE THAT THAT HAS TO DO WITH
WOMEN'S HEALTH.
THAT'S A VERY PRIVATE, HARD, ;
a
.
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULDN'T BE ;
a
INVOLVED AND HASN'T BEEN ;
WOULD WE CHANGE THAT?
>> THIS REMINDED ME OF SOMETHIN;
a
.
YOU SAID THAT YOUR MOTHER TAUGHT
YOU SET YOUR OWN AGENDA OR ;
a
SOMEONE ELSE WILL.
DOES ALL OF THIS REALLY STEM ;
a
OR SOMEONE ELSE WILL.
>> YES, BECAUSE THE AGENDA BEING
SET BY THE UNITED STATES IS ;
a
WOMEN WHEN THEY COME INTO HALLS
OF POWER, THEY INTRODUCE NEW
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT HAVE;
a
HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN THERE ;
LENS ON SOCIETY, AND SO THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE SET THE
AGENDA FOR ALL THE AMERICAN ;
a
.
OUR DEMOCRACY SHOULD REPRESENT
US, AND IT DOES NOT TODAY.;
a
R
ENDORSED PUBLICLY, AM I RIGHT, A
CANDIDATE?
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.;
a
>> DOES THIS -- DOES THAT CHANG;
NOW, MELINDA?
>> NO, I HAVE GIVEN PERSONAL ;
a
RESOURCES AND CONTINUE TO GIF
VE
PERSONAL RESOURCES TO MANY
CANDIDATES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE, BUT I DON'T ENDORSE A ;
a
SPECIFIC PERSON.
>> CAN I ASK YOU WHY, IF YOU'RE;
a
OVERTURNED AS AN EXAMPLE, WHY ;
NOT PUBLICLY ENDORSE IF THERE
ARE CANDIDATES IN THIS NEXT
CYCLE THAT YOU THINK ARE ;
a
?
ELECTION ON BOTH SIDES OF THE ;
a
.
SOMETIMES I VOTE REPUBLICAN, ;
a
OTHER.
I THINK THAT THE BEST POLICY IS
MADE WHEN WE REACH ACROSS THE ;
a
AISLE, AND SO I THINK IF I COME
OUT FOR A PARTICULAR CANDIDATE,;
a
ALWAYS SUPPORTS REPUBLICANS OR
SHE ALWAYS SUPPORTS A DEMOCRAT,
AND THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE ARE FOCUSED O;
a
D
NOT JUST ABOUT WHAT IS AHEAD ;
a
TO THE BIAS BUILT INTO THE
CONSTITUTION, RIGHT?
WHO WAS THE CONSTITUTION WRITTE;
a
BY.
HOW NERVOUS ARE YOU THAT THAT
COULD BE PLAYING OUT AGAIN WHEN;
a
IT COMES TO AI?
>> I'M VERY NERVOUS BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH WOMEN, AGAIN,;
a
.
AGAIN, THE SYSTEM NEEDS TO TAKE
ALL PEOPLE'S POINTS OF VIEW AND;
a
SEE SOCIETY AND QUITE FRANKLY, ;
IS.
WHEN YOU HAVE WOMEN AT ANY OF ;
a
THESE PLACES, WHEN YOU'RE ;
CREATING SOMETHING, WHEN YOU'RE;
a
MAKING THIS DECISION, WHEN ;
YOU'RE SETTING A LAW, YOU'RE
BRINGING THAT PERSPECTIVE OF ;
a
SOCIETY THAT IS JUST SO VITALLY;
IMPORTANT.
>> YOU HAVE, MELINDA, DESCRIBED;
a
THIS MOMENT IN YOUR LIFE AS E
INCREDIBLY JOYFUL.
SO MANY PEOPLE IN AMERICA AND
AROUND THE WORLD HAVE GONE
THROUGH PAINFUL DIVORCES.;
a
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT;
ABOUT YOUR JOURNEY IN FINDING ;
a
THIS JOY?
>> I THINK, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE ;
a
EVEN WHEN YOU GO THROUGH A ;
SEVERAL YEARS, YOU GATHER THESE;
a
MOMENTS OF JOY DURING THE DAY ;
THE END OF THE WEEK.
AND SO I HAPPEN TO BE IN A
SITUATION NOW IN LIFE WHERE I
HAVE A GRANDDAUGHTER.
MY THREE CHILDREN ARE OUT OF THE
HOUSE NOW, AND SO I JUST REALLY
SURROUND MYSELF WITH FAMILY AND;
a
FRIENDS WHO BRING ME A LOT OF ;
KIND OF WORK OR I TRAVEL TO ;
a
PLACES THAT ARE VERY DIFFICULT,;
I CAN LEAN INTO THAT JOY AND
LEAN INTO THAT NETWORK OF FAMIL;
a
AND FRIENDS THAT SUPPORT US. ;
>> I THINK, POPPY, WE TALKED ;
a
K
INTERESTED IN THE ACTUAL
INTERVIEW ITSELF, BUT YOU
MENTIONED IT YESTERDAY, AND I ;
a
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE ;
WHEN YOU TAKE A VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD LINE ON ROE ;
a
VERSUS WADE, AND I'VE SEEN A LOT
OF PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF MONEY I;
a
POLITICS TRY AND STRIKE THIS ;
MIDDLE GROUND AND WITHIN A YEAR;
a
E
COMPLETELY FADED AWAY.
WHAT WAS YOUR --
>> WHY DOESN'T SHE ENDORSE?
I THINK YOU HEARD HER SAY THERE;
a
BECAUSE SHE'S NOT JUST A ;
DEMOCRAT, NOT JUST A REPUBLICAN;
a
SHE'S AN INDEPENDENT, BUT YOU ;
.
I THINK SHE DOESN'T WANT TO
ALIEN AT
ALIENATE PEOPLE.
I THINK SHE BELIEVES THAT SHE
CAN MAKE CHANGE WITHOUT PUBLICL;
a
WRITING THAT SHE DOES.
BUT IT WAS REALLY INTERESTING.
IT'S JUST BEEN FASCINATING OVER;
a
THE LAST DECADE TO WATCH HER ;
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE AND
HEAR A LOT MORE FROM MELINDA
GATES ON THIS FRONT.
MAYBE ONE DAY SHE WILL ENDOR